can we talk about
the future of viruses that might be
threatening the uh our very existence
sure so do you think like a future
natural virus
can um have an order of magnitude
greater
effect on human civilization than
anything we've ever seen
so something that either kills all
humans
or kills i don't know
60 70 percent of humans so some like
something
something um we can't even imagine is
that
is that something that you think is
possible because it seems to have not
have happened yet
so maybe like the entirety
whoever whoever the programmer is of the
simulation that
sort of launched the evolution for the
big bang seems to not want to
destroy us humans or maybe that's the
natural side effect of the evolutionary
process that
humans are useful but do you think it's
possible that the evolutionary process
will produce
a virus that will kill all humans i
think it could
i don't think it's likely and the reason
i don't think it's likely is um
well on the one hand it hasn't happened
yet
uh in part because mobility is
is uh is a recent phenomena
people weren't particularly mobile until
fairly recently now of course now that
we have people flying back and forth
across the globe all the time
the chances of global pandemics has
escalated exponentially of course and so
on the one hand that's part of why it
hasn't happened yet we can look at
things like ebola
now ebola we don't we haven't generally
had major
ebola epidemics in the past not because
ebola wasn't transmitting and infecting
humans
but because they were it was largely
affecting and infecting humans
in disconnected communities so you see
out in
uh in rural parts of africa for example
in western africa you might end up
having isolated ebola outbreaks
but there weren't connections that were
fast enough that would allow people to
then spread it
into the cities of course we saw back in
2014-15
a massive ebola outbreak that
wasn't because it was a new strain of
ebola but it was because there's
new inroads and connections between the
communities and people
got it to the city and so we saw it
start to spread
so that should be a little bit for you
know
foreshadowing of what's to come and now
we have this
pandemic we have 2009 we have this
uh there is a benefit um
or there is sort of a natural check and
this is a kind of latka voltaire
predator prey dynamic kind of systems
ecological systems and mathematics that
uh if you have something that's so
deadly people will respond
uh more maybe with a greater panic
greater sense of panic which alone could
you know destroy humanity
but at the same time like we we now know
that we can lock down
we know that that's possible and so if
this was a worse virus that was actually
killing 60
of people as infecting we would lock
down very quickly
my biggest fear though is let's say that
was happening
you need serious lockdowns if you're
going to keep things going
so the only reason we were able to keep
things going during our lockdowns
is because it wasn't so bad that we were
still able to have people work
in the in the in the grocery stores
still people working the shipping to get
the food onto the shelves
so on the one hand we could probably
figure how to stop the virus
but can we stop the virus without
starving
you know and i'm not sure that that if
this was uh
another acute respiratory virus that say
had a slightly
say it transmitted the same way but say
it actually did worse damage to your
heart but it was like a month later
that people start having heart attacks
in mass you know it's like
not not just one-offs but but really
severe
well that could be a serious problem for
humanity
um so so in some ways i think that there
are lots of ways that we could end up
dying at the hand of a virus i mean
we're already seeing it just i mean my
fear is still
i think coronaviruses have demonstrated
a keen ability to destroy
or to to create outbreaks that can
potentially be deadly
to large numbers of people flu strains
though are still
by and large my concern so you think the
bad one might come from the the flu the
influenza
yeah they the the replication cycle
they're able to genetically recombine in
a way that coronal
viruses aren't they have segmented
genomes which means that they can just
swap out whole parts of their genomes no
problem
repackage them and and then boom you
have a whole antigenic shift
not adrift what that means is that any
on any occasion any day of the
year you can have boom a new whole new
virus that didn't exist yesterday
and now with uh farming and and
industrial livestock
uh we're seeing animals and humans come
into contact much more
just the the uh the opportunities for an
influenza strain
that is unique and deadly to humans uh
increases
all the while transmission and mobility
has increased
it's just a matter of time in my opinion
you